fin da piccola mi insegnarono le buone
maniere mi dicevano che la postura il
portamento erano le cose principali la
passione e le emozioni non erano cose
per una contessina ma a me piaceva
arrampicarmi sugli alberi correre
schiamazzare era una bambina
appassionata mio nonno quando mi vedeva
andare a giocare mi diceva Maria
Cristina corri piano e urla da agio ma
come si fa anche solo pensare a un
controsenso del genere
mia mamma mi avrebbe voluta con la
gonnellina blu e le camicie smerlate mio
padre invece di nascosto mi ricordo che
mi portò a comprare degli stivali da
cowboy
che ancora conservo e quando purtroppo
morì prematuramente io avevo solo 11
anni e mezzo ricordo che mi dissero non
farti vedere piangere in pubblico le
emozioni sono smancerie inutili devi
tenere un comportamento sempre
distaccato da tutto
non era per me quella non era la mia
natura io avevo un fuoco che ardeva fin
da piccola perché tutti quando nasciamo
sappiamo esattamente Che cos'è la
passione così A 18 anni dopo 15 anni di
suore angeliche che cercarono di
rendermi ancora più fredda di quello che
cercò di fare la mia famiglia vidi che
il clan mediterraneo è un villaggio
vacanziero come lo chiamiamo noi cercava
persone per l'equilibrio intrattenitori
hostess qualsiasi cosa pur di poter
essere in un certo senso libera libera
di esprimersi e partì esattamente il
giorno due giorni dopo la maturità con
la fatirica frase di mia madre se esci
da quella porta non rientrerai mai più
spesso i genitori lo dicono ma grazie al
cielo poche volte lo fanno veramente lì
è B il primo assaggio di libertà perché
potevo essere in fondo ogni giorno
diversa ma ero ogni giorno un
personaggio che mi dicevano di essere
anche lì non era per me quel fuoco che
ardeva dentro mi diceva che io dovevo
sperimentare dovevo vivere fuori dagli
schemi Ovviamente con rispetto sempre
del mio prossimo E allora tornando un
poco le pive nel sacco convinci mia
madre a sponsorizzare la mia prima
propria passione la gemmologia mio papà
quando tornava dai suoi innumerevoli
viaggi mi portava dei cristalli delle
pietre semipreziose che io passavo delle
ore a guardare la luce come le
attraversava Come si rifrangeva sulla
superficie e immaginavo dimensioni
diverse da quelle algide e inespressive
dell'Educazione che mi volevano
impartire così riuscì ad andare a New
York a studiare gemmologia ellissi che
fu il secondo
sorso di Libertà a New York puoi essere
chiunque tu voglia nessuno ci fa caso e
quindi ogni giorno tra parrucche
copricapi Veramente io riuscivo a essere
libera
ho viaggiato
ho visitato molti luoghi Ho provato a
sposarmi non ho potuto avere figli e mi
sono detta forse la mia missione è
un'altra forse la mia missione ascoltare
questa passione che mi fa saltare su
tutti i treni che mi passano accanto
anche quelli dei quali avevo il sentore
che andavano a schiantarsi un vero
talento da piccolo kamikaze ma sapete
quando si sbaglia così tanto si impara
anche così tanto Un giorno
non per caso perché per me il caso non
esiste incontrai in un locale Milanese
un ragazzo di bell'aspetto mezzo libico
mezzo tedesco Karim Carim mi disse che
lui era il consigliere dei
sadimohammarial geddafi il figlio
prediletto del Colonnello Gheddafi io
pensai fosse una boutade per fare colpo
invece era vero
quando approfondiamo la conoscenza lui
cercò di convincermi in tutti i modi di
andare a lavorare per loro mi dissero mi
disse Cristina loro sono in fondo dei
beduini si vogliono affacciare l'Europa
e tu saresti perfetta con i tuoi modini
parli le lingue no cari non mi interessa
è una cultura così lontana da me la
Libia poi era sotto il grande embargo
quindi dove sarei andata chi mi avrebbe
protetto
così Un giorno mentre ero nel centro
storico di Milano Karim mi chiamò e mi
disse dove sei karimson come sei vestita
per caso hai indosso qualcosa di
scollato aderente sexy di Karim sono le
quattro del pomeriggio no Allora vieni
perché l'ingegner sa di tutti lo
chiamavano ingegnassati vuole
incontrarti
una voce dentro di me al pari di un
ventriloquo rispose Sì va bene maledetta
questa passione ogni volta di cacciarmi
nei guai un mio caro amico un avvocato
molto importante di Milano un giorno mi
disse Sai Cristina io ho pensato molto a
questo tuo talento di ficcarti
incessantemente nei guai
Tu sei come un pollo e ho già sulla
difensiva Sì un pollo astuto ma un pollo
che ogni volta lascia il suo habitat
naturale il pollaio e va avventurarsi
nel bosco nel bosco anche il lupo più
stupido ti può sbranare è vero Karim mi
stava attraendo del bosco e io accettai
e così la prima volta che atterrai a
Tripoli era febbraio del 2002 Vi ricordo
periodo del grande imbarco mentre stavo
atterrando c'era peraltro in corso una
terribile tempesta di sabbia io cercavo
di vedere quello che succedeva fuori dal
finestrino Ma questo muro di sabbia
impenetrabile non mi permetteva di
vedere niente
pensai alla metafora del pollo ma era
troppo tardi
quando atterrai mi ritirarono il
passaporto e mi portarono letteralmente
come un pacco postale al Grand Hotel Al
quebear che di grande aveva solo le
dimensioni Ormai il passato del re Idris
prima della famiglia cheddafi era
passato
lì mi lasciarono Due lunghi giorni a
decantare da sola senza comunicazioni
perché
il cellulare non funzionava le carte di
credito non funzionavano e non potevo
avere una comunicazione esterna avrei
dovuto lasciare un deposito cauzionale
Ma le carte di credito non funzionano 48
ore dove io
non sapevo neanche che cosa provare
emozione adrenalina paura nessuno sapeva
dove mi trovassi in realtà nemmeno io
sapevo dove mi trovavo
finalmente dopo due lunghi giorni arrivò
l'agognata telefonata Cristina cenerai
con l'ingegner sadi Mi raccomando
Vestiti elegante ma indossa una cosa
consona e sarete solo lui e te va bene
ok e ho curiosa avevo paura ma ero
curiosa
attraverso posti di blocco e militari
Armati Fino Ai Denti Arrivai al Castello
numero 9 una delle tante residenze
omaggiato al colonnello Gheddafi Quella
in particolare in stile marocchino alle
soglie delle dune in realtà per regalata
dal re Hassan del Marocco Allora defunto
per una qualche celebrazione e io mi ero
immaginata Sapete quelle cose alla sera
dalle mille una notte in realtà Al di là
dell'Agnello intero ripieno di frutta
secca e riso che quello che fanno per
gli ospiti di riguardo l'ingegner
ricevette in un modo abbastanza semplice
se non fosse per una coppia di due tigri
albine che passeggiavano mansuetamente
nel parco limitrofo ma mi dissero subito
Cristina La prima frase che imparai in
arabo ma Fish mushkela nessun problema
non hanno più nelle zanne nelle unghie
da quella notte Io rimasi tre anni a
Tripoli
tre anni di passione di adrenalina di
non so neanche come dire perché quando
racconto queste cose delle volte dico no
non sono non è la mia vita è un film un
film per altro che vivevo di una trama
Nemmeno a me conosciuta
mi chiesero di fare cose talmente varie
e variopinte che mai con la mia più
fervida fantasia non solo avrai pensato
di poter ottenere ma di poter portare a
termine una mattina mi svegliarono in
fretta in furia e mi dissero Cristina è
nato il nuovo figlio il re del trono del
re del Marocco Mohamed Sesto Vai scegli
comprali E portagli un regalo Come
faccio andare a dare del Marocco cioè
nessun problema li era tutto ma Fish
Mosca scelse una culla dorata che
dovetti assemblare tipo mobili dell'Ikea
sotto gli occhi attenti di mamma Lalla
salma un'altra volta l'ingegner sati mi
chiese Voglio un mega acquario con degli
squali vivi facile uno degli ultimi
eventi fu la Supercoppa Juventus - Parma
e gli occhi di calcio non sapevo niente
tre anni dove io ho permesso alla
passione di nutrirmi giorno dopo giorno
e di condurmi mano nella mano con una
cultura che vi assicuro Con tutto il
rispetto e l'umiltà la grande umiltà che
mi ha insegnato questo triennio
non avrei mai saputo Come affrontare
ho ricercato questi sentimenti queste
emozioni quando si dice ho attraversato
la steppa l'ho attraversata davvero ho
viaggiato per quattro anni di seguito
tra la Mongolia la Siberia studiando
sciamanesimo
in quei luoghi così deserti forse solo
la passione ti salva perché nel nulla ci
si perde o ci si ritrova io lì proprio
grazie a una delle cerimonie più potenti
sciamaniche la caccia all'anima
sono riuscita a capire
Qual è la mia passione
lo sciamano suona il tamburo per entrare
in estasi scende nel landerworld nel
Mondo Sotterraneo Dove albergano gli
spiriti e lì va a recuperare questa
nostra parte viscerale quella parte più
animale che se noi ascoltassimo non
sbaglieremmo mai perché l'istinto e
quando noi nasciamo sappiamo esattamente
qual è la nostra missione
al ritorno dalla Siberia mi sono resa
conto che forse era un po' come
L'Alchimista Per Paolo quello non c'era
bisogno di andare così lontano ma sapete
la passione si raggiunge solo se prima
ci si libera non c'è passione senza
Libertà ma non c'è libertà senza
passione nelle tribune miste della
Birmania che ho visitato si dice
che se prima non ti sposi non ti unisci
al tuo sposo sotterraneo non potrai mai
amare non potrai mai essere libero e
quando me lo dissero io dissi Sì ho
capito Ma chi è il mio sposo sotterraneo
sono le vostre paure le fobie i dubbi i
sei Ma se vado in Siberia farà freddo Ci
sono delle zanzare così noi siamo degli
eccezionali boicottatori di noi stessi
Il dubbio è il nemico numero uno della
passione anche la paura in un certo
senso non è un buon alleato della
passione Perché
avere troppo coraggio ti espone la paura
un sentimento naturale così come la
passione e come mai ci dimentichiamo di
appassionarci anche alle cose quotidiane
sbagliando così tanto grazie a Dio ho
imparato se avessi più di 15 minuti vi
racconteremo in modo più ampio quello
che ho imparato ma necessariamente devo
riassumere in tre punti
il primo ho imparato a lasciar andare
lasciar andare un dolore la fine di una
relazione un'amicizia
lasciar andare il passato sapete lasciar
andare anche le cose materiali perché
occupano spazio non c'è spazio per nuove
passioni se prima non lo generi
la seconda cosa i giapponesi la
chiamerebbero wasabi e il concetto di
trovare la pace nell'imperfezione
è bellissimo essere ogni giorno la
versione migliore di noi stessi di
continuare a imparare ma arriva un certo
momento in cui dobbiamo un po' abbassare
la guardia e amarci per quello che siamo
accettandoci per quello che siamo
il terzo punto è quello più caro in
assoluto a me
ho capito che la passione e la libertà
di essere me stessa colei che sono
diventata con i miei buffi copricapo e
le mie battute poco aristocratiche E
l'unica cosa per la quale vogliono
lottare L'unica cosa per la quale valga
la pena di lottare e se il mio amico
della metafora del pollo astuto o fesso
disse lui che era astuto se guido fosse
ancora qua Io gli direi sai tu hai
ragione io sarò un pollo ma io ho capito
che nel pollaio nella mia zona di
comfort non c'è passione per me Io ho
bisogno di avventurarmi nel bosco
consapevole che ci può essere un dirupo
un lupo un carnefice travestito da lupo
Io voglio andare nel bosco magari con
un'analisi
prima del rischio o un paracadute ma
ricordatevi una cosa non c'è passione
non c'è sogno non c'è avventura se voi
avrete paura di entrare nel bosco
[Applauso]
[Musica]